[Music]
once upon a time there was a glowing
City protected by Golden Gates known as
Heaven it was ruled by beings of pure
light angels that worshiped good and
shielded all from Evil Lucifer was one
of these angels He was a dreamer with
Fantastical ideas for all of creation
but he was seen as a troublemaker by the
Elders of Heaven for they felt his way
of thinking was dangerous to the order
of their world so he watched as the
Angels began to expand the universe in
their ways from the dust of Earth they
created Adam and Lilith equals as the
first of mankind but despite this Adam
demanded control and Lilith refused to
submit to his will she fled the garden
drawn in by her Fierce Independence
Lucifer found her and the two rebellious
dreamers fell deeply in love together
they wished to share the magic of Free
Will with Humanity offering the fruit of
knowledge to Adam's new bride Eve who
gladly accepted but this gift came with
a curse for with this single active
Disobedience evil finally found its way
into Earth with it a new Realm of
Darkness and sin and the order Heaven
had worked to maintain was shattered as
punishment for their Reckless act Heaven
cast Lucifer and his love into the dark
pit he had created never allowing him to
see the good that came from Humanity
only the cruel and the wicked ashamed
Lucifer lost his will to dream but
Lilith thrived empowering demonkind with
her voice and her songs and as the
numbers of Hell grew so did its power
threatened by this Heaven made a truly
heartless decision that every year they
would send down an army an extermination
to ensure hell and its Sinners could
never rise against
them but Lilith's hope remained and her
dream was passed down to their precious
daughter the princess of
hell don't worry Mom I'll make you
[Music]
proud what there you wa cter do you like
blood violence and depravity of a sexual
nature Oh Daddy I uh do you really
expect me to memorize this whole script
of course you do that's why you're in
hell what would you say if if I told you
there was a place to stay that had none
of that welcome to the hasb been Hotel
your last desperate attempt at Salvation
starts
here so what do you think I'm sorry what
the [__] was that uh yeah one
note this place is about second chances
to convince Heaven the people of hell
can be redeemed hi mister don't [__]
yourself have you ever wanted something
that was so clear in your mind that you
could taste it
you're going to help Sinners [__]
hilarious it's a feeling like a rumbling
in your gut I just hope what I'm trying
to do here will work are you [__]
high here hold this oh my God oh my God
for the first time in my life holy
[__] to we got 24 hours before the
extermination begins let's get to work
and Al I kind of feel unsteady now I
need to be ready for this they're going
to [__] die they're they're going to
die
fight wonet time to take a it is time to
land a hand against the angels and their
deadly threat we cannot make it anymore
the time
is
f it's time I remind everyone why I'm
here I really hope hope that I'm ready
for
this I'm a bad man who never got enough
hugs where's an innocent kid I can sell
crack to who wrote this it's great right
keep
[Music]
going